that helped a lot um as far as the hijab
I always knew you had to wear but for
the first five years of my life I did
not wear it
um the reason being is I was embarrassed
you know I was embarrassed of what
people thought about me and then I as
the years passed by I always knew knew
that I had to wear it and it always felt
bad that I wasn't I always made I asked
I made supplication to Allah oh Allah
please don't let me die without putting
on the hijab you know it just gave me
the power to do that and
um
I one day I said to myself you know I
have people coming into my Pharmacy that
I counsel all the time they come you
know exposing their body parts naked and
however and they come in front of me and
you know and here I am covered up I said
people need to appreciate that and
mostly I need to appreciate that you
know this is Allah gave us as a
protection
and so I said you know enough being
embarrassed you know other people